if you're not aware tbs stands for
turner
broadcasting system and uh a very
special
member of the tbs family is here the man
himself this is very exciting
please welcome here to say hi the
founder of tbs mr ted turner
[Applause]
[Music]
mr turner i just want to say it's a real
honor to have you here
well i'm glad you're honored i am
horrified
right when i left tbs it was a premier
entertainment destination
now they hired some freckled rooster on
steels to destroy it
wait i'm not a rooster on stilts you're
upsetting teddy junior
okay i'm guessing teddy jr is your
stuffed buffalo on wheels
how dare you sir the only thing that
teddy is stuffed with is integrity
look at his face conan he's disgusted by
you
and he lives in his own field
and look at this crowd
you people you people should be ashamed
of yourselves you
marijuana smoking fig newton eating
beatniks
fig newton eating the reefer makes them
crave the news
okay we are not pleased is there
anything about this show that you like
mr turner well one thing i do have to
congratulate you on is this beautiful
set
yes now officially named turner studio
okay no our stage is just called stage
15. it was
until i entered it
that's so stupid don't in any area that
i physically enter is instantly named
after me
there's turner field turner center
and the turner lincoln memorial no no it
is not called the turner lincoln
memorial
uh the people of washington turner dc
insisted
all right that's so stupid it is not
called get your caterer hole
wait wait lily was that teddy what huh
the deal went through oh conan good news
looks like i just bought four billion
square miles of land north of montana
wait a minute wait there's not four
billion square miles
available north of montana well it was
called canada of course once i get up
there it'll be turn around to death
now wait a minute no what
why not just turn a die oh shut up you
wig stand
hey and by the way what kind of man
draws a lavender jetta
i used to sell mary kate quiet nancy
[Music]
as for you people light up another
doobie
and enjoy this freak show you twittering
parasites
let's go teddy